مره اخرى معنا مراسل الجزيره عمر حوراني
عمر اذا تستمر عمليات الانقاذ ورغم مرور
الوقت ما زال هناك في كل مكان تشبث بامل
في وجود ناجين
نعم بالفعل ما زلنا هنا ان نترقب هذه
اللحظات العصيبه التي يعيشها سكان هذه
المنطقه وتعيشها فرق الانقاذ هنا
لعمليه انتشال ضحايا من تحت هذا المبنى
عملي العمليه تجري الان بدقه متناهيه
وهناك حديث على انهم على بعد دقائق من
اخراج احد الاشخاص من تحت انقاض هذا
المنزل وكانت الفرق قد تحدثت عن حدوث شبه
معجزه في هذا المبنى حيث تم انتشال 17
شخصا خمسه عشره منهم على قيد الحياه اثنان
فارقوا كانوا قد فارقوا الحياه رجل وامراه
هناك سبعه اشخاص ما زالوا تحت انقراض هذا
المبنى هم من عائله مؤلفين عائلتين مؤلفه
من سبعه اشخاص تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى الشيء
المفرح
الموجودين هنا وللفرق الانقاذ انه ما زالت
تسمع اصوات الاشخاص العالقين تحت تحت هذا
المبنى اي انه ما يزال هناك فرص لانقاذ
هؤلاء
الاشخاص واتحدث ولهذا المبنى موقف شخصي
لنا كنا قد وصلنا في اللحظات الاولى
لانهيار هذا المبنى بعد دقائق من حدوث
الزلزال وكنا نسمع صوت اشخاص داخل هذا
الركام كانوا يطلبون المساعده وكان موقف
يعني صعب وقاسي جدا ونحن عاجزين لا نستطيع
تقديم اي شيء وصلت فرق الانقاذ وكنا نغني
النفس بان يتم اخراج هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
كانوا يطلبون المساعده وعدت الى هنا بعد
بعد مرور ساعات ولنجد هذه الاخبار المفرحه
بانه تم انتشال 15 شخصا على قيد الحياه من
تحت الان هو يتم انتشال سبعه اخرون وهنا
حديث عن انهم قد يكون قد يكون كلهم او
بعضهم على قيد الحياه ونحن نترقب في بهذه
اللحظات والدقائق اخراج احدهم ويتم العمل
في
بدقه ومعدات حساسه وهذه تشير الى انهم على
مقربه من هذا الشخص منعنا من الاقتراب
بشكل اكبر لنوضح الصوره بشكل اكثر الا انه
يتم المنع وهذا الامر مبرر كون هناك عدد
كبير من الاذوي العوائل هنا في محيط هذا
المبنى كما نشاهد هناك معدات ثقيله موجوده
لانه لا يتم استخدام هذه المعدات في مثل
هذه الحالات حيث يلجا لاستخدام المعدات
الحساسه والبسيطه لعدم ايذاء الاشخاص
الذين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه في تحت
انقاذ هذا المبنى اذا تجهيزات
اعدت لهذا لهذا العمل
لرفع الانقاض هناك ليس هذا هو المبنى
الوحيد هناك عدد من المباني في هنا في وسط
عين تاب يتم ايضا العمل فيها
لانتشال الضحايا من تحت انقاذها وايضا في
المناطق الاخرى المحيطه في ولايه غازي
عنتاب هناك عمل اخر وايضا في الولايات
الجنوب تركيا التي تضررت جراء هذا
جراء هذا الزلزال نتحدث عن الاف نتحدث عن
الاف المباني التي سقطت جراء هذا الزلزال
وجراء الهزات الارتداديه التي حدثت في هذه
في في جنوب تركيا وفي شمال سوريا هناك
ماساه كبيره حدثت وخلف هذا الزلزال هنا
يوجد تجهيزات كما نشاهد هنا فرق طبيه هنا
فرق للدفاع المدني منقذين جميعهم موجودين
هنا لانتشال الضحايا من تحت من تحت
عمر هل هل هل يوجد يقع وسط ولايه غازي
عنتاب غازي عنتاب كما نعرف هي ولايه يعني
قريبه من الحدود السوريه التركيه هل هل
كيف يتم العمل بين جانبي الحدود التركيه
والسوريه
[موسيقى]
المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان انه حتى الان
لم تصل مساعدات الى الشمال السوري كون
تركيا هي بحاجه الى المساعده هي رفعت
للدرجه
الرابعه وطلبت مساعده دوليه
وهي بحاجه الى مساعده فهي لا تستطيع بهذه
الظروف ان تقدم المساعده للشمال السوري
وكهذا الامر يعني موجه للدول القادره على
تقديم المساعدات عبر تركيا الا انه حتى
الان الاخبار الوارده من شمال سوريا وهذه
النداءات التي نسمعها من الدفاع المدني
ومن الجهات المعنيه هناك بانه لم تصل حتى
الان الى شمال السوري مساعدات الشمال
السوري بحاجه الى معدات كالمعدات هذه
المتواجده هنا هنا حالفهم الحظ بان لديهم
تجهيزات كبيره هذه المعدات العملاقه
القادره على رفع هذه من الباطون وهذه
الكميات الكبيره هناك ابنيه سقطت في
الشمال السوري ولا تتوفر هذه المعدات
مشابهه لهذه المعدات لرفعها لرفع الانقاب
بشكل مستمر هناك نداءات استغاثه من الدفاع
المدني
بالداخل السوري من المنظمات الى
بضروره اسراع الدول في ادخال المساعدات
الى الشمال السوري وذلك للمساعده في
عمليات انقاذ الضحايا كنا نستمع ايضا الى
نداءات بانه يوجد مازال هناك امل لاشخاص
يسمع اصواتهم تحت ركام المباني المدمره
شماليه صوره سوريا الا انه لا يوجد
امكانيات لرفع لرفع الانقاض شيء مفرح هنا
ان تجد هذه التجهيزات وهذا العمل وهذا
العمل الضخم لانقاذ المدنيين انت تشعر
بالاسى لعدم توفر هذه المعدات وهذه
الامكانيه في الصور التي نشاهدها عمر
وانشرها مؤلم جدا وانت اقرب بلا شك ولا
الصور التي نشاهدها
وكانه اقتربوا من انتشار احد الاشخاص
بالفعل
نعم نحن طلب منا الصمت في مثل هذه اللحظات
يطلب
عدم الحديث
نعم اذا هذا مراسلنا عمر حوراني وهو موجود
في غازي عنتاب وكما قال في لحظات كان يطلب
من الجميع ان يصمتوا وذلك
للاستماع الى الاشخاص اصوات الاشخاص
الموجودين تحت الانقاذ هذه محاوله كما
يبدو لانتشار احدهم وهي مستمره منذ بعض
الوقت من الحركه التي نراها يبدو وكان
الامر اقترب على امل يعني ان اكون على قيد
الحياه كنا نستمع من عمر قبل قليل كيف انه
اليوم
في الساعات الماضيه كانت هناك عمليه انقاذ
شبهت بالمعجزه ل 17 شخصا انتشروا وكان من
بينهم 15 على قيد الحياه
نعم عمر تفضل نعم عثمان هي لحظات مؤثره
جدا لحظات الترقب انا
تربطني قصه بهذا المبنى كما ذكرت كنت من
اول الواصلين انا وفريق الجزيره الى هذا
المبنى بعد دقائق من حدوث الزلزال وكنا
نستمع الى صوت اشخاص
كانوا يطلبون المساعده تحت هذا
يعني اعطيك فرصه لتلتقط انفاسك وانت يعني
تخنقك العبره انت متاثر لانه لم تستطع ان
تستجيب لمساعدتهم وانت الان تنتظر يعني
هؤلاء هم الاشخاص الذين ربما او الشخص
الذي سمعت صوته تمام المساعده ولم تستطع
فعل ذلك
نعم ان شاء الله يكون حي تماما وقتها كنا
عاجزين عن تقديم اي شيء باستثناء نقل
صوتهم نقل الصوره في محاوله لمؤازره هذه
الدوله ومؤازره سوريا ايضا في هذه المحنه
في هذا الزلزال نحن نحاول ان نقول هكذا
تساعدهم لكي يشاهدها
يا عمر يعني تساعدهم انت والزملائك
نقل صوت هؤلاء هو عمليا مساعده في الحقيقه
لهم نرجو ان يكون لها
اثرها وانت تنقل لنا الصوره من عين المكان
وتنقل صوت هؤلاء الى العالم والى الجهات
المختصه هي التي تاتي
هي مواقف نعم
هي مواقف مؤثره عشناها منذ اللحظه الاولى
انا كنت انا وعيلتي في بناء بالقرب من هذا
البناء وحالفنا الحظ في لحظات مرعبه
بالخروج من
نعم
اعلم يعني هناك علاقه انسانيه
بما انك يعني تعيش في المكان وتعرف المكان
واعلم ان لك الكثير من الاقارب
والاصدقاء ونحن في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نشاهد الزملاء والزميلات وهم هم
جزء من هذا المكان مقيمون في تركيا
يعني تمسهم هذه الكارثه والحقيقه الكثير
منا ايضا جميع يعني كثير من مختلف
الجنسيات لدينا اقرباء واصدقاء وزملاء
موجودين فهذه الكارثه لا تمس تركيا فقط
ولكن تمسال الكثير من الناس في اماكن
كثيره وبالتالي هناك تختلف المشاعر اذا
سمحت لي
[موسيقى]
عثمان اذا سمحت لي هناك امور كثيره لا
يمكن نقلها نحن نشاهد كيف تترقب العائلات
قد يكون لهم اقرباء قد يكون لهم محبين تحت
الانقاض كيف انهم يتطلعون الى سماع خبر او
مشاهده انتشال لاحد الضحايا من تحت من تحت
انقاذ هذا المنزل تحدثنا الى العديد من
العائلات المتاثره بدا عليهم الارهاق هم
في اليوم الثاني يترقبون اخراج عوائل من
تحت عائلتين عائلتين هنا تحت انقاذ هذا
المبنى هذا المبنى من المباني التي حلفها
الحظ ونتمنى ان تكون جميع المباني حدث بها
شيء مشابه لهذا المبنى الذي كما تحدثت
الفرق الانقاذ هنا عن انه حدث امر شبه
معجزه باخراج 15 شخصا قيد الحياه اثنان
منهم اثنان غيرهم فارقوا الحياه ندعو لهم
بالرحمه رجل وامراه وايضا ما زال هناك
عائلتين هنا تحت انقاب هذا المبدا مؤلف
مؤلف من سبع اشخاص
والشيء الذي يدعو الى السرور هو انه ما
زال يسمع اصوات من تحت انقاب هذا المبنى
منذ لحظات طلب منا الصمت بشكل تام
للاستماع الى اشخاص كانوا تحت هذا المبنى
وهذا الامر صار من المتعارف عليه هنا بانه
عند في كل في بين الفينا والاخرى عندما
يكون هناك احتمال لوجود اصوات تحت انقاذ
هذه المباني يطلب من الجميع السكوت بشكل
تام للاستماع لهذه الاصوات لكن الحديث هنا
عن انه يتم العمل
بمعدات دقيقه جدا كما نشاهد لم تم ايقاف
المعدات الثقيله حتى المعدات المتوسطه تم
ايقافها الان يتم العمل بمعدات حساسه جدا
وهذا يشير الى انه تم الاقتراب من الشخص
الذي يعمل على اخراجه وهذا ويتم استخدام
معدات حساسه
لا يتم ايذاء هذا الشخص الذي يتم نحن
مستمرون في نقل الصوره وكما ذكرت معدات
دقيقه وحساسه احيانا طبعا في كثير من
الاحيان يتم الحفر باليد نحن سنستمر مع
هذه الصوره على امل ان شاء الله ان يكون
هناك ناجم تحت الانقاذ ونعود اليك في وقت
لاح